[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
as I first think of it Dear John and
Hank it's a podcast where two brothers
answer your questions give you to be his
advice and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon John
what do you call mm mockingbirds
what do you call mm mockingbirds Hank to
kill a mockingbirds god it's terrible
thank you to Shawn if they're suggesting
that opening [ __ ] Shauna wrote good
morning brothers green one of my
favorite bits that Hank used to do on
vlogbrothers was tell terrible jokes
since you're both father's might I
suggest that you open with some dad
jokes my brother's name is Ryan for real
Shauna Shauna that was a great opening
bit suggestion we got so many wonderful
emails thanks to all of you I also
wanted to highlight Cory's we might try
this one as well Dear John and Hank
perhaps this isn't funny enough to be
the opening bit for a comedy podcast but
I thought it would be awesome if you
guys opened the pod by simply sharing
something good with us it could be a
joke a bit of good news a fun fact
anything that might lighten up the
inevitably miserable uh that it is going
to be well Cory that's a little bit
unnecessarily negative so what should we
call that what would we call that bit
Jon what what is that maybe we could
call that bit one good story so some
weeks you're gonna get dad joke some
weeks you're gonna get one good story
Hank I actually have one good story this
week it's not really uplifting but it's
weird okay okay so there was this couple
named Jerry and Rita alter who lived in
a tiny town in New Mexico called cliff
and they had a secret no Rita altar just
died her husband died five years earlier
and their secret was Hank that 31 years
ago they stole a Willem de Kooning
painting worth an estimated 160 million
dollars and then hung it in their
bedroom for the last 30 years
ah so that
how did they did they not show anybody
it was just for them did they steal it
with the intent answer I guess nobody
knows cuz they're dead now and no one
will ever know how did nobody know that
this was there but they lived in a
three-bedroom ranch house worth like a
hundred and ten thousand dollars and
they had a 116 million dollar painting
hanging in their bedroom
okay I've pulled up a story myself they
look like a lovely couple they do it
look like your average American couple
from the 1970s or 80s in these photos
they look like they could be our parents
John and they seem quite happy and
they've got wine in both of the pictures
so they like wine but also they like
stealing 160 million-dollar paintings I
love it I mean I obviously don't steal
160 million dollar painting people
listening to this podcast no I can give
you one piece of good advice it's that
well but if you do if you do then
definitely just die without having sold
it yeah absolutely
let it go back into the universe don't
try to don't try to sell it and then and
then have that money do it just like
just wait and then you'll be dead and
then nobody will know did you but she
must have known she was just like please
no one go into my house until I die
I don't want to go to jail for the last
extra like the last two months
Jerry alter was also a writer Hank and
he wrote a story called the eye of the
Jaguar in which two people steal wait
for it an emerald that's how that's how
they never find you
they steal an emerald they take it out
of a museum and bring it to their house
and the story concludes and two pairs of
eyes exclusively are there to see it all
oh damn okay what I need to know is if
they also had an Amber right I mean they
let her be searching the house maybe
they have an emerald too so I've read
the part of this article now and they
they so the person who figured that this
out saw it at like an antique shop and
it's like
or they own the antique shop where it
ended up and and they were like actually
I think this is real so they called the
museum and they were like the basically
he's told the receptionist I think I
have a piece of art that was stolen from
you and then the receptionist asked what
piece and he said the de Kooning and she
said hold please all right so this
painting has now been delivered back to
its rightful place and it was definitely
them that stole the painting and they
just held on to it for 30 years so that
they could have their two pairs of eyes
enjoying their emerald what a weird
world John yeah I'm not sure that
technically qualifies as good news but
it's the news that you got my friends
let's move on to some questions from our
listeners this first one comes from
Audrey who asks dear Hank and John my
oldest friend just told me that her
favorite painters are the pre-raphaelite
s' should I still be friends with her I
don't know how to get past this
paintings and pain Audrey John you're
gonna have to handle this one because I
don't like that as far as I can tell the
pre-raphaelites I have no idea no idea
that's the Renaissance no it was a
movement that wanted to go back to a
world free Raphael that is weren't
before Raphael they were like everything
was good back then Raphael ruined
everything
exactly so they were 19th century
artists trying to harken back to a you
know a better time which there's a long
history of of course nothing seems
better than the past due to its being
fixed it's much less scary at least
there's no way that like the world is
going to end in 1854 like it's just not
gonna happen
right exactly everything seems
survivable on account of it having been
survived look I think that there are
times when you can judge your friends
for their tastes and there are times
when you can't and to me this is one of
those times when you don't need to like
it's not
same thing as liking I don't know what's
something that's really reprehensible
Hank Infowars great example it's not
like your best friend said that their
favorite artist is I can't even remember
the name of the host of Infowars well
that's lovely for you I wish I lived in
that world but I'm not gonna say its
name John I have no interest in thank
you thanks I'm looking forward to not
learning it okay so I think you've just
gotta you got to roll with the punches
on this one Audrey
it's gonna be okay alright Hank this
next question comes from April and it's
one of immediate concern Dear John and
Hank how does the Eiffel Towers bathroom
work I was up there a few days ago and I
cannot stop thinking about how on the
second floor they were bathrooms but
nothing underneath them where does it go
in Paris April oh I've never been there
I've never been that do you have you
ever used the toilet in the Eiffel Tower
John it is factually inaccurate for you
to say that you have never been to the
Eiffel Tower I've never been up to the
top of the Eiffel Tower and indeed you
don't need to as April points out the
bathrooms are on the second floor where
we have definitely been together to the
second floor of the Eiffel Tower yes or
all the way to the top did I go to the
top of the Eiffel Tower and forget about
it John I don't know if you went to the
top of the Eiffel Tower
I know I sure as hell didn't well then
we probably didn't boy if I have then I
really shouldn't put anything on my
bucket list because I will just forget
about it everything's leading John I
guess someday I will forget everything
because I will have died I mean it seems
like we switched bodies for this episode
of the podcast so I guess I'll answer
the second so I guess I'll answer the
science question the way it works is
that while there is nothing directly
underneath the bathrooms in the Eiffel
Tower there are pipes that go from
beneath the bathroom and then kind of
like go along the sides of the tower and
then go down into the ground that that
is the way it works that's why there is
a bathroom there
but at least as I can recall there's not
a bathroom like on top of the Eiffel
Tower because that would have been more
of an aesthetic challenge
maybe I mean that ice thing about being
up high is that gravity takes it all
down and that's really what you're
relying on with with pipes is the the
water pressure in the sucking and the
rolling and the gravity so yes otherwise
like there'd be there are so many people
who go to Eiffel Tower then must be
making glass of waste and you don't you
don't want to see how high up the Eiffel
Tower would be if it just like kept
being raised upon the pile of human
human leavings that were not piped away
[Laughter]
that's really that's great thanks for
thanks for that image I'm glad that I
get to go forward in life having to
imagine that I don't remember very much
about being at the Eiffel Tower but I'll
never forget that well now I'm really
curious how how many visitors to the
Eiffel Tower would just have to poop
when they arrived before I'm sure Isis
how to just be completely buried in poop
like how long would it take oh I don't
know I'd like to see some stats on that
I think that's an interesting question
and an important one to answer
probably put aside everything else that
we do with our lives and focus full-time
on that Hank do you know that there's a
picture of me taken just outside the
Eiffel Tower I didn't actually get to
visit it but while we were doing press
stuff for Paper Towns we went outside
the Eiffel Tower to take a picture and
the picture features Cara Delevigne
taking like a rose and like touching it
against my cheek and she looks extremely
put together and high fashion II and I
look like mush lovey self and it's
Sarah's favorite picture of me and she
insists on putting it up like it amid
the rest of our family picture is like
in the family picture hallway so your
children your wife and this fashion
model exactly except for one picture of
car
with her arm around me touching my face
with a flower with the Eiffel Tower in
the background I found it I found it I'm
looking at it right now that is very
weird very weird photo oh man it's on
it's on Pinterest like when car was
taking the picture she was like this is
so weird but she's so good like she's
such a pro she was like sure whatever
I'll go to the Eiffel Tower and touch
you with this weird flower oh man that's
a weird photograph John you look lovely
you look very nice thank you that's my I
was wearing my best suit the good light
wide margin that's better than any suit
I owned by a wide margin that's for sure
my gotta have to get a suit um I mean
yeah you I I have told you this before I
think a lot of times but I'll tell you
again you need to buy a suit it is a
good investment for a person who has
your job but I feel like that's not the
oh man I just found the picture of her
touching me with the rose and it's so
funny we put it on the patreon it's
funny yeah oh man so put it on the
patreon you can go to
patreon.com/scishow and you don't have
to pay or anything to get access to this
sweet sweet picture very lovely and very
weird cute picture of Sarah and me with
Cara and not in the background making
funny faces I'll put that on the patreon
- these are these are adorable it really
was a super fun time in my life even
though that particular day I had to
spend 14 hours in a hotel basement
answering questions from people who only
spoke French it was still it was a great
great trip this next question it comes
from Beth who asks dear Hank and John a
few weeks ago I obtained a vintage
school desk from my in-laws garage sale
while picking it up they mentioned that
there was a freebie item inside the desk
that's exciting that's always exciting
that item turned out to be a random
tooth Oh encased in gold hey nobody
knows who the Tooth originally belonged
to only that they must have had poor
dental hygiene due to the state of the
tooth my question is what should I do
with this tooth I don't want to put it
in the
where I have all of my baby teeth okay
of course you don't
who on earth would suggest that but I
want to give but I don't want to just
have it lying around either any thoughts
or dubious advice would be helpful Beth
John what do you think about having your
baby teeth still do you do having a box
your own baby teeth I have a couple of
my own baby teeth and I did recently
take them out to show them to Henry
who's losing his teeth now you know
losing his baby teeth now and I was like
you know this happened to your dad too
and Henry was like I'm this is gross why
why did you keep these and then that
made me think this is gross why did I
keep them but Beth Beth we're not
talking about you keeping your teeth
which is not fine but a different
question altogether we're talking about
you keeping a stranger's tooth that you
inherited from your in-laws via
purchasing a school desk at their garage
sale you didn't you didn't inherit this
from your in-laws you inherited you
inherited it from a desk you inherited a
tooth from a desk it's just you found
some trash no no you found some trash
covered in gold you need to sell fit of
gold and throw away the tooth however
that works I don't know
I assume you just go to one of the
10,000 places that say we buy gold in
all capital letters yeah and you're like
look this one's wrapped around some
trash can character do you want it I
actually think the best thing that you
can do it in this situation Hank is when
you have a garage sale is just put it
inside of something random like put it
inside of your teddy ruxpin yeah no
teeth no teeth inside of Teddy Ruxpin
that's fine just know you just glue it
you just glue it in less like a molar so
they don't notice it when they first get
the teddy ruxpin but then like when
Teddy Ruxpin starts to talk it he opens
his mouth oh no I just want to thin the
back there's no batteries on the table
you say all you need to get batteries
for it
in the back but it's just teeth just
teeth like ATT ah that's what you do
with your baby teeth you glue them into
your teddy ruxpin and then you sell the
teddy ruxpin for like five bucks at a
garage sale and you scare a child for
life okay well the great news is that
you've got some gold you've got some
gold wraps trash and that's way better
than just trash so that's not nothing
hey Hank do you think that the people
who listened to this podcast even know
what Teddy Ruxpin is it occurs to me
that Teddy Ruxpin might not be a going
concern oh sure let's uh let's do a
quick Twitter poll John and I'll let you
know at the end of the podcast how many
people know what Teddy Ruxpin is I mean
Teddy Ruxpin is old enough that he ran
on cassettes that's all I'm saying
he is a tape based toy John I am old
enough that I ran on cassettes so let's
not be too mean okay fair enough fair
enough just doing the Twitter Paul but
you know what I'm done all right we got
another question this one comes from
Rachel who writes Dear John and Hank my
close friend just told me he was
planning on asking out one of our other
friends to put it lightly
our entire friend group has been waiting
for this day for a year and a half so
I'm nothing short of ecstatic oh there's
one small problem I can't tell anyone
and I'm awful at keeping secrets I'm so
bad at keeping secrets that I can't keep
my own I've known about this for an hour
and I've only told two people that's
that's not good Rachel
well is it us is it are we the two
people no Rachel Rachel you're doing
great doing great
we are the two people now I get your
joke how do I not ruin this surprise I
can't contain myself not from friends
Rachel Rachel I think what if there was
a thing where there was like it was a
website that was like secret keepers and
then you go to secret keepers calm don't
go there because we don't own this
domain I don't know what's there and and
there's somebody there who can listen to
your secret and be like Oh tell me more
that sounds exciting and then you can
just get
all out and tell the city but this is
this isn't my problem when it comes to
keeping secrets my problem is I forget
that it should be a secret and I just
say it well that's obviously not
Rachael's problem Rachel desperately
need someone that she can talk to to
about this secret
well she's found us so that's good we're
providing that service not in a like a
really sort of rapid back-and-forth but
at least there's some communication
going on but yeah maybe there's there's
got to be somebody out there some some
stranger who will listen to your secret
and have you listened to theirs yeah
maybe just go to the mall and walk up to
a stranger and say hey can I tell you a
secret that's a bad idea that's bad
advice I take it back Rachel don't do
that don't do that's like you like
getting a getting chicken McNuggets
you're gonna get chicken McNuggets at
McDonald's and you're like you're like
can I pay with credit and they take the
credit card and you're like hey can I
tell you a secret drive-through and
they're like may I take your order and
you're like yes but first may I tell you
a secret Jim is about to ask out paying
here's my order i order you to listen to
me right now I have to tell you about
cheeseburgers and five minutes of your
time because I need to tell you about
this Pam and Jim situation do not waste
the time of service employees telling
secrets what if there's a horse cuz the
course can't say your secret to anybody
else mm-hmm so what if there's a horse
somewhere nearby that you can talk to if
there are there any nearby horses Rachel
I'm gonna expand Hanks answer just a
little bit and say are there any nearby
mammals that are non-human so if you
don't have a horse which there's a
pretty good chance you don't maybe you
have a cat or a dog and you can go to
your cat and you can be like hey man
hole just kind of tell you a secret
Pam's about to ask out Jim I want to
tell everybody but I'm just gonna tell
you man hole because everybody knows you
named your cat man hole I think we got
it John I think you know that Hank good
names good names for cats go pants good
name more fidgets keep going light house
yep
polar bear yes straw dang it please for
all probably isn't a good one how can
you know so many good names for cats
like pants and polar bear and then also
be the person responsible for straw and
man hole as cats named John I mean let
okay fine you try those four cats go mr.
Wiggles okay Lady Macbeth oh it was
great the Tudor monarchy that's not good
got distracted by Lady Macbeth you could
have just said Tudor well that's a great
cat me yeah John D want to do a serious
question
this one's from anonymous you're a blast
dear podcast sift through her person her
name is Rosie Anna I was born rich like
1% of Americans rich I don't mean to
sound gross or boastful because it's
actually something I struggle with so
here's my question
I hear friends colleagues family
sometimes joke that my accomplishments
were only available to be in the first
place because of my parents my education
my career my relationships etc I'm
afraid maybe they're right part of me
just wants to accept my lot in life and
move on but I also feel like this is
deeply unsatisfying so what's the best
way to get out under the shadow of my
parents triumphs a nun a mouse here's
the thing they are right in the sense
that you do benefit tremendously from
having privileges and from growing up
rich and you have to accept that yeah I
mean it's such a it's we do want to
believe in our agency and that we are
responsible for the outcome of our lives
and that is in many cases true that is
the that is the case that is fact like
we make decisions and we make good ones
and we work hard but it is not the only
part of the picture it's not the only
piece but understanding that that's not
the only piece I think is important that
you have advantages that you didn't
necessarily earn or that you don't
deserve and getting away from the
of like of like my responsibility
like how much am I responsible for what
I have
how much agency have I had in that and
and how much do I deserve what I have
getting away from that I think is really
important and focusing more on what can
I do what have I done how can I make
myself healthier and happier and also
how can I make the people around me and
my society healthier and happier with
the resources that I have and seeing it
as not this like wait around you that
says like oh no I have to I have to have
this thing that differentiates me and
that also to some extent people might
judge me because of into like this is
not a wait it is a resource and I should
be using it to do the best thing that I
can do does that make sense I mean to be
frank Hank this is something that both
our kids are going to grow up with
they're not gonna grow up tremendously
wealthy but they're gonna grow up much
wealthier than most people and so it's
something I've thought a lot about and I
it's also that we grew up in a very
privileged situation relatively speaking
and I think that deserving is the wrong
way to think about it because you don't
deserve the good things that you get in
life you also don't deserve the terrible
things that you get in life like the
fact that Hank grew up with a tremendous
set of privileges does not mean that he
deserves to have ulcerative colitis
I think deserving is just the wrong way
to think about it and instead as Hank
said thinking about it as resources and
what you can do for your social order
for the people around you that's the way
to think about it so anonymous all we
can say is wherever you are in life try
to use your resources thoughtfully and
carefully yeah and it sounds like it
sounds like you are already thinking
about that stuff critically which is you
know good and better than a lot of
people do Hank I've got another question
from anonymous they send in so many
emails Dear John and Hank I'm not 18 yet
but I have recently been thinking about
the Electoral College if you don't know
what the Electoral College is because
you don't live in the United States
don't worry about it if I am a Democrat
that lives in Colorado or Wyoming does
my vote even matter or if I'm a
Republican living in California
since these contrasting since these
states never reflect a significant
amount of fuel from the opposite side
and elections does my vote go away as it
is in the minority should I move to Ohio
just to have more of an influence
Georgian Democrat anonymous
first off anonymous there's a pretty
good chance that being a Democrat in
Georgia is going to be super relevant in
presidential elections if not in the
next cycle then like maybe two cycles
from now so don't move please secondly I
think that what gets lost in a lot of
these conversations is that while the
person who is president is very
important in United States politics it
is not the only important thing it is
not the only important elected office
local offices Congress the Senate these
are so important and if we had a
different Congress we would have a
different country and so that's what I
would say wherever you are it makes
sense to vote even if you know the
candidates you're going to vote for are
going to lose it still makes sense to
vote because it still sends a statement
to the people in power that their power
is less secure than they believed it to
be it's it's and if you don't vote all
that says is I don't exist in this
district
according to myself I am willing to be
anonymous in this district I am willing
to be anonymous in my community I am
willing for my political voice not to be
heard and I don't I don't think that is
a good strategy any elected
representative knows and they might not
because of you know a lot of division
right now they might not people to like
represent this accurately or do a good
job of it but but they have to know that
their job is to not represent just the
people who voted for them their job is
to represent all of the people who live
in the place where they are and it is
much easier to do that if you see that
there is a diversity of people in your
place and and that's true nationally
it's it's true locally and it's true on
the state level and and so having a
diversity of voices at the polls you
is extremely valuable and that that like
that feeling that like it won't matter
for me to go out and do this that can be
that can suppress that that instinct for
it can suppress people from going to the
polls if they think that their candidate
is just going to lose but that results
in even further polarization of the
system yeah exactly
so please I know that you're not 18 yet
Georgia
well you're not named Georgia you just
lay up there we don't know in my yeah
whatever they are named Georgia I'm
sticking with it I know that you're not
18 yet Georgia but when you are hope
that you will register to vote and vote
and everyone out there who lives in the
United States or any place where you're
lucky enough to be able to vote for your
leaders I really really encourage you to
register to vote if you live in the US
you can go to vote gov right now make
sure that you're registered make sure
your registration is up to date and if
you're not registered get registered now
because there are big extremely
important elections in November it's
true that there is no presidential
election but nonetheless the elections
in November are tremendously important
indeed and I also want to say to
everybody out there who's named the same
name as the place where they lives that
must be weird like George like all the
people named Georgia and Georgia all the
people named Orlando and Orlando that's
just got to be weird
hmm that's all all the Washington's in
Washington yeah there's got to be tons
of them yeah the Oregon's in Oregon I
don't know how many Oregon's there are
in Oregon but you know I bet there are a
ton of Dakotas in the Dakotas oh yeah
Tom and Virginia's in Virginia what is
the state Hank where there are the
fewest people named the name of the
state in the state I'm gonna guess it's
Wyoming yeah just because there aren't a
lot of people in Wyoming and the rels
are not a very normal name yeah yeah
like I bet there's a lot of Cheyenne's
in Wyoming but I don't think there's a
lot of Wyoming's in Wyoming I bet your
bet you're right I was gonna go with
Alaska but Alaska is actually a pretty
common name especially because you made
it a name in the book and now more
people maybe or more alike
people that it is a much more popular
name certainly than it was in 2005 I
don't know that I made it happen but it
is a weird coincidence I'm not sure that
we want to conflate correlation and
causation but I did recently look at
like a baby-naming website and there are
more people named Alaska after the
publication of that book than before it
which is a weird thing to think about I
think it's I think you did it I think
you did that I mean I used to I remember
when our like when I when we were trying
to name our kids I spent so much time on
baby name websites yeah and then it's I
mean it is a big deal it is a big deal
you don't want it you don't want to you
want to name your kid the right name
that's for sure okay so okay okay all
right Hank I've got I've got some actual
stats here for you in 2004 three babies
per million were named Alaska in the
United States in 2017 49 babies per
million were named Alaska in the United
States so again I don't know the
extension working for Alaska is
responsible for that but it is it has
gone up by a factor of 15 or so and
after this Hulu show John everybody's
gonna be named Alaska well we'll see
about that
I mean some people say it's gonna be the
new Emily or Claire I don't even what
even is the most popular name right John
can you tell me because apparently you
know about a web site I don't know about
how many kids in America are named
Wyoming uh yeah absolutely
Wyoming is not in the top 10,000 names
for either boys or girls hmm I found a
website saying that Wyoming is the
seventeen thousand four hundred and
thirty-third most popular name for a
girl which how many babies are born in
America every year because I feel like
that's probably like last that's just
like there's one everything is tied for
seventeen there's always one every year
there's one way oh yeah I think that's a
beautiful thought I think it's not by
the way it's not a bad name now that I
wanted to be pretty good name for a boy
or a girl like I feel like if I met
somebody
and they walked up to me and they are
like hello my name is Wyoming Johnson I
would be like I mean that person's
probably up to something interesting or
cat this next question comes from Pia
who asks dear Hank and John what would
happen if we put the earth into a big
box and blocked all the sunlight from
from it for just one second
my friend says it would damage the earth
considerably and we'd be really in
trouble but I feel like that's a bit
dramatic like surely the earth would
survive without one second of light love
the podcast by the way I always listen
to it while I'm doing my morning
workouts so feel free to encourage me
because I probably feel like I'm dying
right now
dftba Pia move it Pia up down left right
up down left right forward backward
those are all the directions
obviously Hank is trying to encourage
you to remember how to do the Contra
video game code not how to workout
you've got it Pia keep going up up down
down left right left right B a B a start
great job Pia keep it going keep it
going
up up down down left right left right
good I know how to work out John what
was the question oh I think we'd be fine
yeah we would be totally fun one second
one second of no light we would be okay
yeah I mean I think that uh I think with
that level of very a like I think it
might be somewhat of a big deal you
might you might see a little blanket
maybe a measurable drop in global
temperature that day but ya know by far
the biggest issue with this idea is uh
is the construction of this big box
which would consume all of the earth's
resources and also who would only be
around for one second and then what are
we gonna do with it
just kind of crash back down to the
earth it's gonna fall down as rain in
particles of giant cardboard I don't
know what we made it I can't figure out
what to do with gold-covered teeth how
are we gonna possibly figure out what to
do with an
earth-sized bucks what's it made of
also we didn't need to build a whole box
we could have just blocks the Sun that's
not that big yeah you know who this
would be a big issue for would be me
because if all light on earth for one
second went away I would be really
freaked out for that one second because
when there's even like a brief dimming
of lights in a room that I'm in I'm
always like Sarah did the lights just
dim are the lights did you feel like the
lights just flickered did the lights can
somebody confirm for me that the lights
flickered because I'm scared that I'm
having a stroke I was really you know I
that the solar eclipse happened fairly
recently yeah and I remember went over
over Montana and I didn't experience the
full Eclipse though I really wish I
could have and I really need to make it
happen someday but but just going
outside and watching it through my
Eclipse glasses I was shocked by how
cold it got during the Eclipse and I
guess like of course this makes sense
the Sun isn't radiating on me anymore
but the temperature dropped like ten
degrees and the the Eclipse was never
fall so it still looked like there was a
Sun in the sky but it's just like got
chilly it was really cool no it's wild
man it's why it's weird such a weird
thing we are so differences I'm tired on
that death laser up in the sky I know
thank God for that death laser which
reminds me John that this podcast is
brought to you by the deadly laser Sun
the deadly laser Sun it's making you
look old today's podcast is also brought
to you by Teddy Ruxpin Teddy Ruxpin
now featuring old human teeth guests
it's also brought to you by I don't know
if you've heard about our new sponsor
the giant pile of poop under the Eiffel
Tower the giant pile of poop under the
Eiffel Tower the more tourists visit the
bigger it gets then lastly today's
podcast is brought to you by cats named
Tudor monarchy cats named Tudor monarchy
even rarer than humans named Wyoming
it's true I looked it up on the the baby
the baby cat named list that the census
puts out its
No so far nobody but John also this
podcast is brought to you by the last
two weeks but also John this podcast is
brought to you by that last week of the
pod con IndieGoGo so if you want to come
and see us do a live dear Hank and John
and I live delete this and a live
Anthropocene reviewed you can go to pod
con comm and there's a link there to our
crowdfunding campaign where you can get
discounted tickets and also things that
are only available during the campaign
we very much appreciate people who are
able to buy tickets early that's why we
make them cheaper and also encourage you
to do it because it makes it a lot
easier to plan a conference and less
terrifying
so pod con calm it's gonna be lots of
fun also we have a project for awesome
message to read from Stewart Baker Thank
You Stewart for donating to the project
for awesome this year to get us to read
this on the podcast dear Hank and John I
discovered the vlogbrothers through
crash course world history
I enjoy the weekly vlog because of the
respect and humility that you bring to
this editorial format you discuss
important issues facing our shared world
with suggestions on how we might
collectively help to end world suck
thank you for creating the project for
awesome and the peace of mind that it
brings with knowing our contributions
make an impactful difference well that
is very nice of you Stuart you I would
be happy to read that any time not just
for money absolutely let's come back to
it read it tomorrow but after that after
that yeah how how extraordinarily
generous I have to say thank you to
everybody who donated the project for
awesome to get dear Hank and John
related perks this year
I think they've at last all gone out our
tradition of sending out Perks seven
months late continues and will continue
into next year so look for this year's
project for awesome toward the end of
the year so that you can get perk seven
months later this this left I've got
another question John
it's from Rachel who asks dear Hank and
John I recently went to book con and
received a temporary tattoo of the
sculptures from an absolutely remarkable
thing which comes up September 25th is
available for pre-order now my question
is where and when do I apply this tattoo
do I wait for the release of the book or
a special day like Labor Day or I do it
just wear a face tattoo one day to work
is there some specific part of my body
where I should be applying this tattoo
Thanks
so no one told you life was gonna be
this Rachel Wow that's our second
friends related Rachel second John I
have no idea I just wanted to say that
because I wanted to put my book oh I
feel like I must I think it's important
to plug your book we should also plug
the tour if you live in say New York or
Boston or California or Indianapolis or
Chicago or many other places you should
come see us on tour Hank green calm you
can go and get tickets and they come
with a free book and a great show it'll
be super fun I'm only on the first part
of the tour so that's that's that's the
ones that you should get tickets for SIA
west coast
it'll just be Hank yeah it'll just be
Hank so my rule of thumb is to apply a
temporary tattoo as quickly as possible
and in a place where you would
conceivably want to get a real tattoo
but not like one of the places where you
would get a real tattoo that only you
and people who know you intimately would
see so like the bicep the forearm maybe
your all that kind of thing
neck yeah one time when Sarah worked at
an art gallery in Chicago like when we
first started dating they had a show
where the artists made temporary tattoos
out of all of the artworks that were in
the show and we got all of these
temporary tattoos and Sarah had to like
as part of her you know like employment
managing the gallery like have one of
the temporary tattoos all the time you
know a little is a little weird and one
of them was you know the song 99
balloons lift what is it it's called 99
lifts balloons 99 lift balloons one of
them was that it was like an
illustration of that or like an artwork
based on that song that German song and
anyway this story is super-important
Hank and I'm getting to its point the
point is
the point is that one time we were like
she it was on her upper arm and we were
counting the freaking 99 lift balloons
and there was a 100th lift balloon it
wasn't even an accurate artwork about
the song that it was supposed to be
about did you did you destroy it like
there's ways to destroy temporary
tattoos job no I mean it's just I don't
I don't really recall what happened to
the temporary tattoo but that whole it
was like an eight week period where she
had to have one of the artworks you know
on her body
okay it's weird art is weird maybe we
should all be pre Rafi Oh lights let's
stop being so weird let's just go back
to book two before the Renaissance when
everything was normal
yeah exactly Dark Ages when people died
of smallpox at ten just a normal life
but when you didn't when you survived
you made art sometimes I guess I think
we got another question this one comes
from Devon and it's a very good question
Dear John and Hank
my work often stalks the Trader Joe's
Key Lime tea cookies which is all fine
and well they're delicious I have one
problem though my boss has commented
multiple times upon finishing one that
they are quote spicy now it keeps me up
at night because I don't know if it's my
place or my responsibility to tell a 40
year old man that limes are in fact sour
not trying to sour a work relationship
Devon I know I know that this might
sound weird but there's a there words
have meanings we can't just go around
calling a lime spicy can't do it we're
not gonna stand for it I love this close
to beer
Alice calls every food that is not
extremely bland spicy so to Alice if
something is physically hot you know
like if it is very warm mm-hmm she'll
take a bite of it and she'll be a spicy
and then that's cute but this is not a
child this is a
your old man also if something is
excessively salted she'll take a bite of
it and she'll be like spicy yeah it
contains spices I guess yeah the best
one though my favorite one is when she
like eats a sweet tart and I guess maybe
this does get to Devon's point she'll
eat a sweet tart and she'll say hmm
sugary but spicy well if apparently
that's what this this boss person is
saying yeah but this is a sugary this is
sugar spice it's possible Devon that
nobody like what if I never correct
Alice and one day she's in a work
environment at the age of 40 and she's
like god these are great spicy lime
cookies I don't think in general it's
very hard it's very hard to correct
people when they're do it when they're
doing something wrong that seems very
obvious it's hard when it's hard even
when your peers but especially when it's
a person you know in a position of
authority it just feels very wrong to be
like look sir that's as that's not what
spicy is I don't know what to say
right now it's the are unicorns
endangered problem at the moment
somebody says to you are unicorns
endangered you're in a heck of a pickle
it's like hi don't know where to start
with this baby he thinks there's yeah I
see maybe there's like some ginger in
there and it's giving him a little
tingle here's what you do Devin you get
your boss some sour patch kids for I
don't know what their birthday or
something mmm and then they eat the sour
patch kids and they're like wow spicy
but they look at the packaging and it
doesn't say spicy patch kids it says
sour patch kids and that's gonna be the
moment of Revelation and you don't have
to do anything right right right and you
also you also get like some some like
red hot cheetos too and you're like
here's your birthday difference between
these just that but do you get it up and
then you just can repeat this process
every year forever until finally they
get it yeah I love it
also Devin I love that you work is
somewhere that has these very good
sounding cookie
I very jealous that's all that's mostly
it but also John can we now from now on
just call sour things spicy around our
employees so that they think that they
have to figure out how to handle this
problem cuz is it possible that this
boss knows full well that they are not
spicy and it's just playing a fun little
dad joke here it's just it's it's all
for a gag it's pasta it's possible it
could be a bit but I suspect that it's
just a little bit of misinformation that
sour patch kids can correct nobody
nobody thinks that sour patch kids are
an educational tool until they are you
know until you know it it really is it
is about how these items are used in our
lives John we're gonna do one more
question before we get to the news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon it this one is
from sunny D like the the juice I guess
the very very spicy juice dear Hank and
John I was watching some old
vlogbrothers videos when you were on
tour and you mentioned to question
Tuesday video about how everyday you
both will be abandoning one opinion
until you have to come to some true core
opinions always wondering did you ever
figure out what those core opinions are
did you strategy work it's been a while
since I really thought about it and I
wanted to reaffirm my values and
opinions I'm just not sure how to go
about it like the orange juice Sunny D I
do have a I do feel like I have a couple
core opinions that have been revealed
partly through the process of trying to
give up more of my opinions although I
haven't been giving up nearly enough of
them to be fair the biggest core opinion
I have is that hope is the correct
response to human consciousness that
like hope is not a delusion or a lie we
tell ourselves in order to find a way to
go on it's actually correct human lives
have value and that compassion should
always be a component of how you
approach the world in other people
another of my core opinions is that AFC
Wimbledon is the greatest achievement in
the history of the human species well I
guess then that we should go into the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon John I
hear that AFC Wimbledon played a game
did they play a game we played a game
we're back the long long summer has
finally come to an end although
you wouldn't know it based on the
weather in London these days but yes yes
wimbledon are back and not only are they
back Hank we won our first game in Ligue
1 the first time we have won an opening
day match in six years not only that we
were away from home not only that we
were playing fleetwood who were a
playoff team last year and they won one
nil and not only that there has been a
huge huge upgrade in the quality of the
AFC wimbledon watching experience for
the non english fan hmm you can get the
my follow AFC wimbledon app it is not
cheap to get the TV coverage but the TV
coverage lets you watch the games on
your phone or your tablet with
commentary so last year there was no
commentary and there was no scoreboard
so you just had to kind of remember what
was happening but now it's like a
regular TV experience except with the
radio w do n commentators who are
hilarious and so charming and so like
watching it is now also a pleasure but i
watched the entire game and it was
joyful wimbledon looked better in my
opinion than they looked all of last
season the goal itself was hideous jo
bigoted the made stony and messy or as i
guess we're gonna be calling him joey
pigs joey pig scored in the 60th minute
and it was a really ugly finish he just
barely got a foot on the ball and it
kind of dribbled into the goal but they
all count the same and we've been really
dominated the game fleetwood did hit the
inside of the post from like 30 yards
out with a beautiful shot late in the
game but I thought Wimbledon deserved to
win and we did win which great so off to
a roaring start thanks to a goal from
Joe Piggott a lot of the new players
looked good Mitchie pins Mitch pinic
looked good a very encouraging very very
encouraging first game for
AFC Wimbledon you don't want to get
ahead of yourself of course it's a long
season 45 games to go we're gonna win
the league get those points John well
the news from Mars John is you know not
super great there's what was this hope
that people have talked about that maybe
there's enough carbon dioxide on the
surface of Mars
in Mars is like sort of like inside of
the regolith inside of the ice caps
frozen in in little pieces that if you
could warm it up a little bit that co2
would release into the atmosphere and
then that would create sort of a heat
trapping layer that would then get warm
it up more and more carbon dioxide would
be released and then you would get more
and more co2 until suddenly just a
little bit of warming resulted in a lot
of warming and it was warm enough maybe
and ended up with enough atmospheric
pressure even that you could walk
outside you couldn't walk outside
without an oxygen mask on so that you
could breathe the atmosphere but you
could walk outside without like you know
suffering from decompression or or being
extremely extremely extremely cold so
that would be really cool but we've got
two new sets of data in that are
signaling that there probably isn't
enough carbon dioxide trapped on the
surface and dry ice or even trapped in
the rocks and soil of Mars that if we
released all of it all of it this is
what the study says it would create 15
millibars of atmospheric pressure is
that a lot right now you're probably
know you're probably sitting at a
thousand millibars right now where you
are and view and ah and that would not I
can show you if you all one thousand
millimeters I feel a lot of atmosphere
around me it's holding all your all your
parts in its holdin holdin of it's
pushing all that that good oxygen into
your lungs it's great it's good for you
but 15 millibars would be bad for you so
that's not gonna be the only thing we
need to terraform Mars I'm not saying
that there's maybe like no way to do it
you just have to find other ways to turn
the rocks on Mars into gas
because it's not this gonna be the co2
that's sitting around on the surface of
Mars that will do it unless we're super
wrong about something which hey we might
be because look Mars is far away and we
can only study it in very specific
locations where we have Landers or by
like sort of shooting shooting different
science beams at it and studying the
results of the science beams hey you
know I don't think that that's a
terrible terrible way to put it you
don't want me to get into the details of
how all these things work right now we
do that another episodes but I just
wanted to talk about the likeliness of
that particular terraforming
terraforming scheme not being super
simple we'll have to find some other
some other places to get that those
gases from alright good to know
well I still believe that we will
terraform Mars but only after we destroy
Earth right right yeah I mean the
problem with Mars is like I just feel
like if I'm living on Mars it's gonna be
so hard for me to get like the really
good food that I like from Earth like is
there it is do they do they have post
mates on Mars
like I guess once there's people there
there'll be Mars post Bates for
emergency deliveries of Indian food one
of the people who wrote in this week
Hank suggested that the new AFC
wimbledon goalkeeper tom king should be
known as the keeper of the castle and i
like that a lot
oh yeah because he's the king and the
keeper of the castle it's it's great
it's perfect so I just wanted to get
that out there
the keeper of the castle Tom King I
don't know that's it that's all I wanted
to say I was listening you talked about
Mars but I was looking at AFC Wimbledon
starting lineup you know we all have to
indulge in the things that we love John
it's also this was episode 150 of dear
Hank and John so thank you to everybody
for listening to 150 episodes of dear
Hank and John if you've done that if you
haven't they're still on the iTunes on
our RSS servers if you want it
to them or you know it doesn't hurt our
feelings if you don't ya know start
today make this the first one you ever
listen to so you have no idea about the
manhole joke earlier yeah or the fact
that we got another question from Pia
and I'm wondering if it's the same Pia
Pia and the long con of the violinist oh
my god is it the same here look it up
look it up it's a different PA job okay
good to know I'm glad I'm glad that we
established that
hey Hank did you use your phrase of the
week this week I did use my phrase of
the week this week John did you use
yours I used mine yes do you want to
guess what mine was I got it I gotta
tell you I have no idea I wasn't paying
attention at all it was the 100th lift
balloon and it was not easy but I did it
oh my so that's why you made us keep
that and yes that's why you made us keep
that story yes because it is the only
way that I could figure out to put in
the 100th lift balloon you just you're
just a liar you just lie about things
yeah I just make up stories Sara did
once have an art gallery show at her
gallery in which there were temporary
tattoos involved but nothing of that
level of complexity what was your phrase
the week I also have no idea what it was
it was emergency take out got it at the
end there oh wow I mean that makes sense
because why else would you be talking
about post mates on Mars but I was
already looking at an see where are we
starting line up for their next game I
got saved I got saved by John's
distractibility John what like I can't
believe we're gonna I was like I'm so
excited we're gonna be starting been
pouring turnout on let the left what I'm
sorry what's going on why would you do
it what did we learn today oh man we
learned that been pouring tons the
likely starting left back for next
week's game if we weren't if you want to
get something over John's head just wait
until you look at a football stuff we've
learnt we've learned that if you want to
keep a secret
just drive through oh my god
and we also learned John the difference
between spicy and sour it's very
important yeah is the
sniffing indifference there's no doubt
about that we learned that there are at
least two people in the world named
Rachel who are concerned about their
relationship with the show friends and
according to the Twitter poll that I
just looked at we learned that more than
half of people who responded do not know
who or what Teddy Ruxpin is well and
also you didn't get any explanation for
who or what Teddy Ruxpin is in this
episode so sorry sorry about that it's a
creepy animatronic bear that talks to
you great that's ya know that that about
covers it we're off to record our
patreon only podcast this week and
Ryan's the worst ten minutes of your
week you can find out about it at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
thank you again to everyone for
listening this podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins it's produced by
rosianna halse rojas and sheridan Gibson
are director of community and
communications as Victoria bon giorno
the music that you're listening to right
now and at the beginning of the podcast
is by the great gunnarolla I'm Hank
green on Twitter nope I'm John Green on
Twitter Hank is Hank green on Twitter
you can also email us at Hank and John
at gmail.com thanks again for listening
and as they say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome
[Music]
you